hey there townscapers
today i want to show you the tour for
chapter two of connecting small towns
tomorrow i'll start uploading chapter
three i really think you guys will like
what's going on in chapter three so i'm
really really excited about that
uh i want to keep this commentary short
but i just want to say
thank you to all of the people who have
shown me genuine love and support
i really really really appreciate it and
this channel is doing
way better than i thought it would and
it's because of all of you so
thank you again thank you thank you
thank you thank you please keep doing
what you are doing
please keep viewing please keep liking
please keep sharing and i will continue
to bring you new and improved content
if you haven't already hit that
subscribe button and make sure that you
like and comment
because i didn't i really needed uh as
stated previously this series is pretty
much just me
connecting small towns while practicing
uh so you'll be seeing me improve
throughout this series
if you have seen some of my footage this
video will feature buildings that you
may recognize from sessions seven
through twelve if you haven't seen them
or you just want to view them again the
playlist will be linked in the card in
the upper right corner of this video
along with some tips and tricks and my
random clicking playlist which is my
favorite thing to do
obviously if you haven't seen my random
clicking series you can see the original
challenge video linked below
i was really really happy to see that i
inspired others to try this challenge
and just see what comes up and the
results were
really amazing um anyways that's it for
me
please enjoy this video please make sure
that you like and subscribe because it
helps me out a lot
make sure that you follow me on
instagram and twitter and again thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you so much for viewing like seriously
guys i really appreciate it
and i can't wait to see how far i can go
with this channel because you guys are
really showing me some love
anyways i'll see you next time
[Music]
hey townscaper if you're hearing this
that means you made it to the end
i want to thank you so much for viewing
please make sure that you like and
subscribe when you like and subscribe
it really helps channel out a lot please
make sure you follow me on instagram and
twitter
the links are down below in the
description and again i want to thank
you so much for checking in and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you